c'est pas finalement insupportable de
cette séparé dans la vie parce qu'on
avait plus envie de vivre ensemble et
d'être obligé pour vivre de de se voir
sans arrêt pour chanter alors je vais te
répondre
c'est insupportable
bonsoir
bonjour jeune homme ça va jeune homme ça
va jeune homme toujours là
on peut dire ton âge non ça te fait
chier si on dit pas du tout 58 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
vous sortez une compilation qui n'est
pas qu'une compilation d'ailleurs ce
n'est pas qu'une combination donc voilà
donc il y a plein de trucs il y a je
sais plus combien de place il y a 22
morceaux c'est donc
Eric Charden votre père était directeur
du port d'aliphones votre mère était
tibétaine mais à lassa
la famille sa famille a été massacrée
c'est enfui vers la frontière
indochinoise et en fait vous avez
aujourd'hui comme je l'ai dit 58 ans
mais vous vivez toujours 57 vous vivez
toujours avec votre mère et on va voir
pourquoi et comment magnéto Serge
oui et puis c'est maman c'est surtout ma
mère qui est là
qui est dans la vie une vierge tu peux
l'avoir même si ça te fait bizarre mais
elle est là et je suis très fier quand
la film ce soir elle est là
ah ouais ouais
ici c'est elle qui me l'a demandé ça
c'est toujours fait elle vit avec moi et
c'est génial elle a jamais été aussi
présente dans ma vie
tu sais maman est tibétaine elle est née
à la salle
et elle est arrivée à la frontière
indochinoise quand tous les
après avoir eu toute ma famille
massacrée par les Chinois
et puis moi je suis là le bonheur de
naître de sortir du ventre de ma mère
quand
quand elle m'a mis au monde là-bas
voilà
Éric Charden mais oui vit avec les
cendres de sa maman et c'est même votre
maman qui vous l'a demandé tout à fait
elle vit entouré de ses objets je dis
bien une vie parce qu'elle vit vraiment
moi c'est quelque chose d'extraordinaire
de d'être en communication je veux dire
un truc bon c'est pas très gai mais
c'est très à la fois je trouve ça
formidable elle avait une maladie elle
est partie d'une maladie horrible qui
s'appelle la maladie d'Alzheimer et
j'avais plus aucune communication avec
maman et le jour où il y a eu cette
barrière qui ce qui est parti avec avec
elle quoi c'est extraordinaire j'ai plus
de nouveau communiqué avec maman d'une
façon
c'est fabuleux quoi je suis très heureux
ça c'est une émission qu'on a fait
ensemble en 95 le Paris dernière et donc
elle vit toujours sur dans cette urne au
milieu de la vigne vierge tout à fait et
toujours là plus plus que jamais dans
tous les matins il passe là il fait le
petit coup de chiffon c'est ça rejoint
un peu le sketchs
incinération
voulait être chanteuse d'opéra
de l'époque l'histoire de Stone et
Charden elle est très simple donc lui il
arrive de de vous arriver d'Indochine
vous allez à la scène chez les Maristes
tout à fait à Paris vous habitez chez un
peintre Maé et puis un jour chez ce
peintre un petit bien se faire tirer le
portrait enfin c'est un type qui bossait
dans le disque et c'est comme ça que
vous rentrez dans le disque vous ne
savez pas du tout il faisait la gueule
et comme Henri Mahé Henri Mahé faisant
une petite parenthèse si on a lu Le
Voyage au bout de la nuit quand Céline
revient des États-Unis il engage un mec
pour ouvrir et fermer les portes du
cabinet quoi médical la barbouille c'est
c'est lui c'est drôle et alors voilà
donc un jour vous rentrez dans le disque
comme dans la chanson comme ça et vous
bah vous avez fait plein de petits plein
de petits boulots et vous arrivez au Bus
Palladium et ce n'est Charden se sont
rencontrés au Bus Palladium
discothèque à la mode du moment quoi on
s'est rencontré là parce qu'il y a une
élection c'est plus Miss beatnique
vous avez pas voté vous avez voté pour
une autre fille mais c'est c'est vous
appelez Annie gautra hein c'est Annie
qui a été élu quand je suis sorti de mon
sommeil profond
elle est belle j'ai pas voté pour elle
mais très très belle alors votre famille
était très très énervé après vous parce
que vous aviez arrêté à HEC pour faire
de la chanson et vous avez épouser Annie
vous qui donne une famille niveau disons
un peu quand vous épousé la fille d'un
employé des SNCF ça refait un scandale
qui moi
ça c'est bien passé
c'est juste sur le moment après
les problèmes commencent vous vous avez
fait l'Olympia à la première fois
enceinte et quand votre enfant né votre
enfant à tous les deux Baptiste nez il
est plutôt envie de vous occuper de lui
non c'est ça oui mais hélas ça c'est pas
fait comme je l'ai pas le temps c'était
pas possible
c'est une chose et comment ça se fait
donc après vous avez continué à bosser
ensemble ou à chanter ensemble à faire
des galets ensemble vous avez fait un
disque solo qui a eu un qui a eu un
certain succès c'est ça
dans les t-shirts dans les maillots
et puis après vous avez quand même
jamais rien fait de comparable au succès
que vous avez vu dans les dans les
années 70
pourquoi
je suis feignant que je sais pas
on sait jamais d'avance c'est une
chanson va marcher ou pas c'est ça qui
est fou quoi impossible
elle a été jeté à la poubelle dans les
radios directes ça a été instantané
voilà c'est sûr bien sûr donc il a fallu
que le public toujours ça soit lui qui
demande le disque est-ce que c'est pas
finalement insupportable de cette séparé
dans la vie parce qu'on avait plus envie
de vivre ensemble et d'être obligé pour
vivre de se voir sans arrêt pour chanter
alors je vais te répondre
au contraire c'est vachement mieux comme
ça c'est très bien
parce que justement on a plus les
problèmes de couple les problèmes de
rivalité machin on est tranquille qu'on
est bien dans on est bien dans nos vies
et puis tout va bien
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
dans SLC bien sûr alors je vais vous
faire une interview SLC on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai repris le SLC le numéro doute 1973
et donc je vais vous reposer les mêmes
questions et puis je vais voir si vous
répondez pareil alors par exemple on
vous demandait dans ce numéro de SNC en
août 73 est-ce qu'un ménage d'artistes
peut rester unis
on disait oui bien sûr
lui disait cette malédiction ne nous
concerne pas
en fait c'est vrai pour les idoles pas
vrai pour les artistes et en plus on
s'aime tellement
dans le même genre
vous vous répondiez moi le problème se
pose pas toute façon parce que je suis
pas une véritable artiste je pourrais
m'arrêter du jour au lendemain je l'aime
pas c'est encore vrai
des défauts
alors vous
Eric Charden quel défaut vous attribuiez
à l'époque à Stone
essentiel essentiel le retard mais ça a
pas changé Stone toujours en retard même
au mariage elle était en retard ce qui
m'a mis en rage dites-vous à l'époque
mais tout à fait voilà
c'est insupportable
et elle disait ce sont ces rages qui
sont son principal défaut voilà c'est
bon on est raccord après on vous posez
salut les copains c'est George Renou qui
avait fait le
vous poser une question sur les
intéresse tu écoutes l'émission tu me
dois 50 000
les extraterrestres et les civilisations
disparus vous répondiez quoi vous venez
vous y croyez aux extraterrestres
complètement complètement complètement
vous disiez la Terre a été visité il y a
21000 ans j'ai ajouté je crois qu'il y a
des mutants sur la terre fumier quoi
ah non non moi pas du tout non non c'est
pourquoi ah non bah c'est son truc ça
c'est pas le mien
à l'époque
vous vous souvenez sur quoi
sur Léo Ferré oh là là et sur la peine
de mort vous étiez pour la peine de mort
j'espère que vous avez changé d'avis pas
tout à fait je suis désolé mais non même
pas ça doit être pour ça les catholique
tu ne tueras point
il y a des exemples de tonicat alors
vous parlez de carrière solo à tous les
deux et vous disiez vous on se retirera
sur la pointe des pieds ça n'a pas été
le cas finalement un petit peu
on est content
la même chose donc c'est vrai on peut
rallumer la lumière
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu